unitó de la capacidad de la humanidad en
el espacio por primera vez la NASA logró
cambiar la órbita de un asteroide a
millones de kilómetros de distancia
hoy la NASA confirma que dar cambió la
trayectoria del asteroide objetivo
[Música]
hace dos semanas la NASA había
confirmado que la Sonda Dark del tamaño
de una máquina expendedora había
impactado contra el asteroide divorcios
un cuerpo Celeste de 160 kilómetros de
diámetro parecido a la luna
pero la gran incógnita era si había
logrado modificar su trayectoria la
confirmación responde al cálculo de su
órbita sobre otro asteroide tras semanas
de observación a través de telescopios
antes del impacto de dark dimorfos tardó
11 horas y 55 minutos en órbitar su
asteroide padre más grande vivimos
y ahora el equipo ha confirmado que el
impacto de la nave espacial alteró la
órbita de dimorfos alrededor de didimos
en 32 minutos y por lo tanto movió con
éxito su trayectoria
con un presupuesto de 330 millones de
dólares y siete años de planeación la
misión tenía un objetivo a largo plazo
labrar el camino para desviar futuros
asteroides que podrían impactar a la
tierra
esto tiene claro ventajas para asegurar
la capacidad de la humanidad de desviar
posibles asteroides amenazantes en el
futuro también habla de lo lejos que ha
llegado nuestro programa espacial en los
años
ahora el camino sigue siendo largo y
Según los científicos debe haber una
cooperación global para poder
identificar las rocas espaciales que
existen y también para determinar su
composición